لا شك ان زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجات على مقياس
ريختر سيخلف دمارا في اي مكان حضاريا في
العالم لكن حين تتهالك كل الطوابق فوق
بعضها البعض فهذا يزيد من اعداد الضحايا
ويساعد من عمليات الانقاذ فما هي قصه
مباني الطوابق الناعمه عاده ما يتم ازاله
عناصر التدعيم من الطوابق الارضيه ويتم
استبدالها باعمده فقط لخلق مساحات كافيه
للمحال التجاريه وهنا المشكله الاولى في
الطوابق الارضيه الاعمده وحدها تكون في
الغالب غير قادره على امتصاص الاهتزازات
ثاني مشاكل هذا التصميم تكمن في ان الطابق
الارضي يحتوي على جدران اقل من باقي
الادوار وهو ما يترك بعض الجدران في
الطابق الارضي غير متصله بباقي جدران
المبنى هذا يعني ان ارضيه البناء اساسها
الذي تستند فيها اضعف من الطوابق العلويه
ولهذا السبب عندما تهتز الارضيه نتيجه
لزلزال ينهار الطابق السفلي اولا ثم تسقط
بقيه الادوار فوقه فيما يعرف بانهيار
الفطيره مما يجعل المبنى معرضا بشده للتلف
في الزلزال الحل اذا هل يقتصر على هدم
جميع المباني القديمه وبناء غيرها في
الواقع لا يمكن اعاده هيكله المبنى وذلك
عن طريق استبدال الاعمده الضعيفه في
الطابق الارضي بهياكل الفولاذيه او تقويه
الجدران الحامله بحديد التسليح المزيد من
الفولاذ يعني هياكل اكثر مقاومه للزلازل
لذا تشهد عمليه رفع الانقاض حاليا عزل
الحديد والكلاب عن باقي مواد البناء وذلك
من اجل التاكد من مدى التزام المقاولين
بالمعايير اخر تحديث لهذه المعايير كان في
2018 ونص على استخدام خرسانه عاليه الجوده
مسلحه باسياخ من الصلب المضلع من اجل بناء
اعمده راسيه ودعامات خرسانيه افقيه
لامتصاص اثر الهزات لكن هذه العمليه مكلفه
للغايه